cette vidéo est sponsorisée par pandacraft des
kits éducatifs pour enfants
à découvrir en fin de vidéo.
[Musique]
Paul connais-tu le plus grand désert au monde
? l'Antarctique exactement 14000 milliers de
kilomètres² ça vous étonne? attendez d'apprendre
ce que les fremen vont faire à Dame Jessic-- je
suis présentement en train de faire tomber
ma caméra je suis présentement dans le karoo
sud-africain qui est un désert semi-aride les
déserts c'est caractérisé par la sécheresse et
je confirme que j'ai jamais vécu une sécheresse
pareille j'ai besoin de me mettre des gouttes
dans tous les orifices parce que vraiment
c'est critique un désert c'est moins de 250
mm de précipitations par an moins de 500 mm
pour les zones semi-arides comme le karoo où
je me trouvais juste avant bref dans ces zones
il y a plus d'eau qui s'évapore que d'eau qui
tombe et les déserts c'est des milieux extrêmes
même pour les températures c'est les endroits
les plus chauds pour les déserts chauds
et les plus froids pour les déserts froids
et c'est là qu'on enregistre des records absolus
de température vers le glagla comme vers le
oulala mon string de Borat est trempé de transpi
on a très très peu de nuages dans ces écosystèmes
donc sans cette couverture nuageuse la terre
absorbe davantage d'énergie solaire le jour
et en émet davantage vers l'espace la nuit il
y a pas d'entre deux les nuages ne permettent
ni de renvoyer une partie des rayonnements
solaires pour qu'il y fasse bon le jour ni
d'en emprisonner une partie des infrarouges la
nuit pour éviter qu'on s'y pelle le jonc et oui
ça sent le vécu et un autre truc ici c'est qu'il
y a aussi énormément de vent là aujourd'hui ça va
à peu près donc j'ai bien choisi mon jour pour
tourner mais d'habitude c'est un peu terrible
donc tout ce que j'ai tourné sur le terrain
je pense que je vais sans doute faire de la
voix off dessus parce que sinon ça va ressembler
à ça [__] putain le vent là le vent commence à
se lever et je suis ravie d'avoir oublié
mes bonnettes de micro on considère que
30 % de toute la surface terrestre est aride
donc c'est quand même un petit peu énorme ça
ça va dépendre de la latitude du terrain et des
conditions atmosphériques enfin de la circulation
atmosphérique là je me suis auto spoilé mais si
j'ai bien fait mon travail la question qui vous
taraude à présent à part pourquoi Renaud continue
de se produire sur scène et qu'a bien pu devenir
le professeur Raoult c'est pourquoi les déserts
sont secs à vous durcir le pain de mie si vous
mettez plus de 10 minutes à manger votre sandwich
? Eh bien c'est à cause des chevaux les latitudes
des chevaux c'est un peu comme la diagonale du
vide mais avec moins d'Isère et plus de désert
et oui parce que les zones arides ne sont pas
localisées à la va comme je te pousse elles sont
généralement entre 30 et 35 degrés de latitude
de part et d'autre de l'équateur la faute à la
circulation atmosphérique qui forme des cellules
de convection à la surface du globe de l'équateur
au pôle cellule de Hadley de Ferrel et cellule
polaire à l'équateur l'air chaud et humide
s'élève fait son petit footing du matin urine
sur les tropiques sous forme de bonne grosse
pluie et poursuit sa route en direction des pôles
avec le genre de sécheresse qui nécessiterait de
consulter un gynéco vers nos chevaux susmentionnés
cet air rencontre l'air de la cellule de Ferrel
qui se dirige vers l'équateur lui aussi sec
comme un pruneau et les deux décident de faire
un bout de chemin ensemble et plongent la tête
la première vers le sol et paf ils nous créent
ces ceintures arides vers 30° Nord et Sud là
donc où on retrouve pas mal de nos déserts
favoris c'est quoi votre désert préféré ? moi
c'est le diramizu et donc c'est aussi pour ça
que ces régions sont si venteuse la faute aux
chevaux mais tous les déserts ne sont pas dans
ces latitudes cavalières comme par exemple
l'un des déserts les plus secs au monde le
désert d'atacama au Chili c'est le petit chouchou
des astronomes pour une bonne raison c'est qu'on
y trouve des observatoires à la pelle mais plutôt
des observatoires astronomiques forcément on voit
bien les étoiles vu qu'il y a pas de nuages ni de
pollution lumineuse et qu'on est en altitude le
karoo c'était pas atacama mais j'ai pu prendre
quelques photos sympatoches du ciel avec un
matériel pas du tout adapté par exemple ça c'est
pris au smartphone je vous laisse imaginer ce que
ça donnait en vrai mais je m'égare bon mais
alors pourquoi il est sec à takama s'il est
pas aux bonnes latitudes et pourquoi c'est même le
désert le plus sexe au monde ? parce que les Andes
lui font de l'ombre de l'ombre pluviométrique
pour faire court les vents grimpent en altitude
quand ils survolent les montagnes l'air devient
plus froid et peut donc transporter moins d'eau
c'est pas moi qui décide c'est la physique il se
déleste de ses pluies ou de ses neiges sur les
Andes et arrive tout sec sur Atacama et c'est
d'autant plus amplifié que la région jouxte un
courant océanique froid et puis il y a aussi les
déserts polaires dont Zendaia nous parlait en tout
début de vidéo avec l'Antarctique encore une fois
c'est la faute à la circulation atmosphérique bon
maintenant qu'on sait pourquoi un désert se forme
là où il se forme on va pouvoir attaquer la vraie
question comment un désert se forme ? c'est là que
ça devient intéressant ça on va parler de cailloux
j'aime bien les cailloux AE a Aï le retour du vent
j'ai lu qu'il y avait moins d'érosion dans les
déserts qu'ailleurs parce qu'en fait le principal
facteur érosif je sais pas si c'est comme ça qu'on
dit c'est l'eau et du coup bah comme il y a moins
d'eau dans les déserts bah il y a moins d'érosion
après pour en avoir discuté avec Julien dans
tractosciences qui est paléontologue ici qui
connaît bien le terrain il m'a dit que c'était pas
forcément le cas donc je vais vous montrer un peu
ce qu'il m'a raconté
[musique]
il y a pas que le vent qui érode les roches
dans le désert il y a aussi la température
on l'a dit entre le jour et la nuit les écarts
peuvent dépasser 40°C ça fait que les roches se
dilatent se contractent se dilatent se contratent
se dilactent se contractent je sais pas parler au
bout d'un moment elles n'en puissent plus un
peu comme vous en ce moment tel un sphincter
accro au Tabasco elles fissurent puis éclatent en
plein de petits morceaux c'est la thermoclastie
et c'est l'heure de freiner sur le piment et
c'est là que le vent prend le relais il va
transporter les fragments de roche et selon leur
taille les faire rouler ou les faire sautiller
sur le sol on appelle ça la reptation et
la saltation je peux vous dire que quand
les particules vous saltationnent dans la face
vous les sentez bien passer les particules de
sable et de poussière peuvent être transporté
comme ça sur de grandes distances les français
métropolitains se rappelleront peut-être de ce
ciel apocalyptique coloré par le sable du Sahara
en 2022 il y a aussi la poussière chinoise qui
se retrouve régulièrement à Hawaï 10000 km plus
loin plus hardcore les vraies tempêtes de sable
génèrent carrément des champs électromagnétiques
les particules dans l'air celles qui reptationnent
et celles qui saltatent se collisionnent en diable
et deviennent électriquement chargées ça peut
causer des étincelles et des interférences avec
les télécommunications quand même mais sans aller
jusqu'à invoquer des tempêtes de sable et autres
scénarios catastrophes le simple transport
des particules par le vent c'est déjà rigolo
en soi puisque ces particules qui étaient
un produit de l'érosion deviennent un agent
de l'érosion hilarant n'est-ce pas je vous avais
bien dit quand elles sont transportées par le vent
elles vont rouler taper sur les surfaces alentours
et les abraser les abrasir abrasoir ? elles vont
polir les roches un peu à l'image du papier de
verre et à force d'éroder les roches on peut
aboutir à des énormes étendues de fines particules
très reconnaissables au microscope tellement elles
ont été émoussées particules dont le sable que
vous voyez ici même si seulement 20 % des déserts
sont des déserts de sable des ergs c'est moins
fréquent que ce qu'on imagine le reste du temps il
s'agit de regs des déserts de cailloux débarrassés
de leur sable par le vent voilà c'était le point
mots fléchés certaines roches peuvent même se
mettre à arborer un genre de patine naturelle
qu'on appelle le vernis du désert un phénomène
qu'on peut voir ici sur des roches martiennes
ou ici dans l'Utah vernis qui a été gratté il y a
2000 ans par les Premières nations pour former ce
paléo street art un petit peu impressionnant ce
qui est marrant c'est qu'ici la végétation s'est
vraiment adaptée justement à la sécheresse et au
vent donc on voit des plantes qui sont très basses
qui ont un port prostré qui ont des toutes petites
feuilles pour retenir l'eau et qu'elle s'évapore
pas trop enfin c'est assez rigolo de voir tout ça
c'est un peu une garrigue un peu pimpée quoi il y
a des Acacias qui ont des épines commasse je pense
que c'est pour se protéger en fait de la pression
de prédation pression de broutage des animaux
parce qu'il y a masse d'animaux ici notamment
pas mal de vaches je sais pas si on les voit
derrière moi pas du tout faites comme si [Musique]
[Musique] semblant [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [Musique]
revenons-en au désert de sable un peu parce
qu'ils sont particulièrement intéressants côté
géologie ce sable grâce au vent toujours peut
se ranger en jolies rides typiquement éloignées
de quelques centimètres les unes des autres et
perpendiculaires à la direction du vent ça ne
vous rappelle rien ? et oui c'est le même genre
de structure qui se forme à la plage et qui peut
fossiliser tel quelle je ne résiste pas à l'envie
de vous montrer les magnifiques ripple marks qu'on
a vu en Afrique du Sud parce que vous savez que
c'est une de mes figures géologiques préférées
et et on en a vu plein et elles étaient vraiment
très très belles or donc quel que soit l'agent de
transport air ou eau on aboutit au même genre de
structure car les mêmes processus sont impliqués
dans les deux cas la seule différence ou l'une
des seules c'est que dans le cas des rides formées
par le vent les particules les plus grosses
s'accumulent en haut des crêtes alors que les
plus petites vont au fond des creux où elles
sont protégées du vent quand les rides sont
formées par l'eau bah c'est l'inverse fun fact
vous avais dit qu'on allait s'amuser aujourd'hui
et puis s'il y a assez de matière le sable peut
carrément s'assembler pour former des dunes voire
des systèmes dunaires les fameux ergs dont on
parlait au début des scientifiques qui avaient
décidément trop de temps libre se sont même
amusés à faire les mathématiques des dunes un
grain de sable grimpe la dune avec un angle
de 10 à 20° et il la redescend avec un angle
de 32° environ vous pourrez pas avoir un angle
plus aigu quand on atteint 32° paf c'est obligé
de dégringoler et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait
que les dunes sont pratiquement un truc vivant
elles avancent progressivement avec le vent un
grain de sable à la fois pas besoin de désert
exotique pour ça d'ailleurs c'est aussi le cas
de la dune du Pilat han sur la côte atlantique
la dune du Pilat-han et du coup comme la dune
suit la direction du vent si les vents tournent
on peut avoir des belles structures géologiques
qui se mettent en place un peu comme celle-ci je
sais pas vous moi je suis je suis restée
en admiration devant cette photo pendant
une demi-heure j'exagère même pas et j'étais
sobre et alors vous ne devinerez jamais mais
on trouve aussi des dunes de sable sous l'océan
en fait les processus sont tellement similaires
qu'il y a une moto qui passe dans la rue
que les chercheurs reproduisent des dunes en
laboratoire dans des aquariums en remplaçant
le vent par de l'eau ça leur permet de faire des
dunes miniatures de les faire évoluer en plusieurs
minutes voire heures plutôt que d'attendre
dans la nature plusieurs années et les dunes
en laboratoire sont en tout point comparables
au dunes de nos déserts voilà je trouve ça assez
rigolo que les les chercheurs fassent des déserts
miniatures sur leur paillasse on n'arrête pas le
progrès on arrête le progrès et figurez-vous
que ces dunes peuvent aussi traverser les âges
comme les déserts c'est un environnement très
particulier du point de vue climatique notamment
il y a des structures géologiques qui sont propres
aux déserts qui se forment que ici comme notamment
les lœss et donc ça ça n'a rien à voir mais je
voulais vous la montrer parce qu'en fait il y a
pas de ici mais en fait je voulais faire un plan
reportage pour donner du rythme à la vidéo vous
voyez alors là je faisais la maline à dire qu'il
y avait pas de lœss ici mais la suite du voyage
allait me réserver une petite surprise dites donc
[Musique]
pour voir les structures dont je parlais
il faut se décaler un peu donc là on a fait
8h de route on est à mafubé et alors derrière
moi il y a ce que j'ai appelé des lœss alors des
lœss c'est quoi en fait c'est des dunes de sable
qui ont fossilisé telles quelles et c'est un peu
beau et alors l'Afrique du Sud est quand même
extrêmement bien lotie pour ça parce que c'est
juste un modèle dans les cours de géologie bah
c'est ça qu'on montre je dis lœss mais si monsieur
phi était là il dirait less parce que il a un
peu à cheval sur la prononciation du E dans l'O
mais comme faire semblant de s'y connaître
ça va 2 secondes je vais plutôt demander à
Julien c'est quoi le lœss, less, loess ? Le lœss
alors ce sont des sédiments qui sont déposés par
le vent donc là ce qu'on a derrière nous ici
cette énorme grès c'est la formation Clarens
qui date du début du Jurassique qui a environ
180 millions d'années c'est un dépôt qui s'est
formé dans un désert qui ressemblait au Sahara et
ce sont des dunes dans lesquelles les dinosaures
ont mis les pieds et à tel point qu'on trouve
des empreintes de dinosaures un peu partout
en voilà une juste là
là en plus ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
c'est qu'on a pas seulement des empreintes de
dinosaures on a même une piste du coup puisqu'on
a 1 2 3 empreintes donc pied droit pied gauche
et repied droit là-bas en dessous d'Erin qui
ont été faites par un dinosaure qui avait trois
doigts au pied donc probablement un carnivore ce
qu'il y a d'intéressant avec ces empreintes
c'est qu'il y a des équations qui permettre
de reconstituer la vitesse des dinosaures grâce
à ces empreintes on va savoir comment l'animal
se déplaçait quelle était la longueur de ses pas
et cetera et en plus ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
c'est que ces empreintes nous montrent comment
l'animal vivait contrairement à un squelette où
on a comment l'animal est mort ces empreintes là
elles ont été faites par un animal de son vivant
et ça ça nous montre exactement la biologie
de cet animal et donc en Afrique du Sud on a
vraiment cette chance d'avoir les bushman qui ont
fait des des peintures de ces empreintes au milieu
des années 1800 ils ont découvert ces fossiles
et ils les ont interprétés ils ont fait des
peintures rupestres de ces fossiles et ils ont
fait une reconstruction de ce qu'ils pensaient
être l'animal qui avait fait ces empreintes
et ces reconstructions étaient très précises
ressemblaient exactement à un dinosaure et quand
on les compare à celle que Richard Owen a fait à
la même époque qui était un gros dinosaure
balourd avec la queue qui traînait en fait
on se rend compte que les bushmen avaient mieux
interprété ce à quoi ressemblait un dinosaure
que Richard Owen lui-même Richard Owen qui est
le créateur du mot dinosaure je le rappelle donc
c'est pas n'importe qui c'est parce que Richard
Owen s'est basé sur les os alors que les Buchmen
eux se sont basés sur les empreintes ils ont vu
déjà qu'il y avait pas d'empreinte de mains donc
on est sur un animal qui marchait uniquement sur
ses pattes de derrière alors que si on avait eu
un animal qui qui était quadrupède on aurait eu à
chaque fois empreinte de mains empreinte de pied
empreinte de mains empreinte de pieds et cetera et
ils ont vu que la queue qui si elle avait traîné
aurait dû laisser une marque ici exactement comme
ça le fait chez les crocodiles or là il n'y a rien
la queue était soulevée du sol exactement comme
vous voyez dans le film Jurassic Park alors là
figurez-vous que on a trouvé un fossile je dis on
c'est pas moi du tout mais Olebeng une étudiante
de Julien qui a trouvé un fossile en direct
elle est là pointe vers le bas ah oui ah
ouais très très beau là je me suis rapprochée
je sais pas si vous voyez ça c'est une griffe
ça aussi et l'autre doit être par là mais je la
vois pas très bien et en passant les empreintes
qu'on vous a montré là elles sont vraiment toutes
nouvelles enfin pas littéralement mais on vient de
les découvrir par que l'experte en empreintes de
dinosaures du coin ne connaît pas ces empreintes
vraiment là on est en train de parcourir le site
de découvrir plein de choses je sais pas si vous
voyez les découvreurs par là-bas on s'amuse bien
je voulais vous remercier d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas à me dire ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires et puis on se retrouve bientôt
pour d'autres vidéos sur le karoo je remercie
Julien d'entracte science parce que c'est grâce
à lui qu'on est là et c'est grâce à vous grâce à
vos généreux dons c'est pour ça que je suis là
avec Pumba et Pumba et plein d'autres que vous
allez voir très bientôt j'espère pouvoir
vous montrer un peu l'envers du décor avec
des formats cours et des formats long sur la
chaîne dans les semaines voire mois à venir
voilà donc j'espère que ça vous ira et que
ça apportera un peu de soleil dans vos vies
et ça tombe bien qu'on parle de désert parce
que vous savez ce qu'il y a aussi dans le désert
l'Égypte et c'est justement le thème du kit pandac
craft de ce mois-ci dites donc pour ceux qui ne
les connaissent pas panda craft ce sont des kits
éducatifs pour vos bambbins chaque mois par la
poste votre petite madeleine votre archibalde
receverra un colis comprenant un magazine
éducatif une activité manuelle et son guide
le tout sur un thème donné qui change tous les
en décembre on célèbre la mythologie égyptienne
en janvier les volcans en février les Romains
joyeuse fête romain en plus il y en a pour tous
les âges un abonnement pour les 3 5 ans un autre
pour les 5 8 ans et un troisème pour les 8 12
ans j'ai pu tester ces kits je peux vous dire
que je me suis diverstruite en diable c'est une
activité très rigolote à faire avec son enfant
ou ou son enfant intérieur et c'est justement
l'occasion de découvrir les kits de ce mois-ci
pour les 3 à 5 ans un super magazine oh c'est
beau ça prépare Noël et l'activité un chambou
tout avec les dieux égyptiens ça c'est toutes
les consignes oh ça va chambouler pour les 5 h
ans nous avons les dieux d'Égypte ils sont beaux
les magazines en plus à chaque fois et l'activité
la course des dieux fabrique ton jeu de société
et sois le premier à emmener ton Dieu en haut du
podium une bonne activité du mercredi après-midi
et enfin pour les plus grands j'adore ce magazine
là parce qu'il y a toujours des fun fact très
rigolo et c'est hyper bien écrit activité le
défi des dieux fabrique ton jeu sur les dieux
égyptiens et jou et en plus s'il y a un souci
pour le montage il y a des QR codes avec des
vidéos de démonstration ça c'est toutes les
carte pour jouer un D la boîte pour ranger les
cartes en plus c'est hyper beau je sais pas si
vous voyez la qualité du du truc je connais
des neveux qui vont être un peu contents de
recevoir un cadeau de Noël qui n'en finira plus
puisque chaque mois il y en aura un nouveau mais
surtout leur dites pas ce sera une surprise vous
aussi offrez à vos Peet un cadeau qui se vivra
toute l'année imaginez les étoiles dans leurs
yeux à l'idée de fabriquer des machins et des
bidules tout en apprenant des trucs et grâce à ma
générosité sans born ellisabeth bénéficier d'une
réduction de 15 % sur votre abonnement ou vos
abonnement soyons fou une offre exceptionnelle
valable pendant un mois à retrouver grâce au
code promo Fiona et à mon lien est en description
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo merci
à pandacraft de l'avoir sponsorisée la
prochaine sur l'Afrique du Sud
parlera peut-être de cratère
de météorites je sais pas dans le
doute abondance-vous la cloche :)
[Musique]